Okay,
let's make a start.
So I hope everyone had a good,
a good break.
We're going to spend this week looking at repeated interaction.
Are we ready?
You saw last time before the break that we,
once we were repeated games,
those games go on for a while.
We can sustain behavior.
That's quite interesting.
So for example,
before the break we saw that we could sustain fighting my players that we're
rational in a,
in a war of attrition.
All right.
And I don't think we learned before the break was when we're analyzing these
potentially very long games,
it helps sometimes to break it,
break the analysis up into what we might call stage games each,
each period of the game and break the payoffs up into the pay offs that are
associated with that stage pay off that are associated with the past,
but they're sunk.
They didn't really matter and pay off or they're going to come in the future
from future equilibrium play.
So there's just some ideas we're going to pick up today.
But for that,
for the most part,
what we do today will be new.
Now,
where as last time we focused on fighting for the whole of today,
I want to focus on the issue of cooperation about the whole of this week.
I want to issue out a focus on the issue of cooperation.
And the question kind of a behind the everything this week is going to be Canada
repeated interaction among players both induce I'm sustain cooperative behavior
or if you like good behavior,
I know canonical example is going to be prisoner's dilemma way back and the very
first class we talked about prisoner's dilemma and we mentioned that playing the
game repeatedly might be able to get us out of the dilemma.
It might be able to enable us to sustain cooperation.
All right?
And what's gonna be good about that is not justice team cooperation,
but Justine team corporation without the use of outside payments such as
contracts or the mafia or whatever.
All right.
So why does this matter?
Well,
one reason it matters is that most interactions in society either don't or
perhaps even can't relate,
uh,
rely on contracts right?
The most,
most relationships are not contractual,
however many relationships are repeaters.
All right,
so he's going to be of more important perhaps in general life don't have lesser
in business,
more important in general life van or thinking about contracts.
So just think about some obvious examples.
Think about your own friendships.
I don't know if you have any friendships,
I assume you do,
but for those of you who do,
your friendships are typically not contractual.
You don't have a contract that says,
if you're nice to me,
I'll be nice to you know,
right.
Similarly think about interactions among nations interactions during nations
typically can not be contractual because the new to enforce those interact,
uh,
those,
those would be contract so that you can have treaties I suppose.
But most interaction,
my late nations,
that cooperation my nation is,
is this famed by the fact that those,
that those relationships are going to go on forever.
Right?
And even in business,
even while we have contracts and even in a very litigious society like the u s
which were the most litigious society in the world,
we can't really rely on contracts for everyday business.
And a business relationships.
All right,
so in some sense we need a way to model a way to sustain cooperation and good
and good behavior that forms,
if you like the social fabric of our society.
I was always going to court about everything.
All right,
now why you might repeat it?
Interaction work.
Why do we think,
what do we think?
Way Back in day one of the class that repeated interaction might be able to
enable us to behave well even in situations like prisoners,
dilemmas or situations involving moral hazard where bad behavior is going to
occur in one shot.
Games.
All right,
so the lesson we're going to be sort of underlying things today and all week is
this one.
Yeah,
an ongoing and ongoing relationships.
It ongoing relationships,
the promise,
all future
rewards
and
the threat.
Oh,
future punishments,
future punishment.
Me,
let's be careful.
May sometimes
may sometimes provide
incentives
for good behavior today
and just leave a gap here.
But in your notes,
because we're going to come back to this,
this is a very general idea.
The idea is that future behavior in the relationship,
it can generate the possibility of future rewards,
our and or future punishments and those promises or threats may sometimes
provide incentives for people to behave well today and I'm in get like what
reason would leave a gap here is I want part of the purpose of this week's
lectures to be trying to get beyond this.
This is kind of a almost a platitude,
right?
Thank you.
Most of you knew this already.
All right,
so I want to get me on this.
I want to see when,
when is this going to work?
When does it not going to work?
How is it going to work?
All right,
so I don't want to do,
I don't want people to leave the week,
leave this week of classes or leave the course thinking,
oh well this relationship is going to kind of going to a,
we're going to interact more than once,
so everything's fine.
That's not true.
All right?
What do we want to make sure that we understand when things work,
how they work,
and more importantly when they don't work and how they don't work.
All right,
so we're going to try and fill in the gap that we've just left on that board as
we go on today.
All right?
Nevertheless,
we do have this very strong intuition,
that repeated interaction.
We'll get us as it were out of the prisoner's dilemma.
So why don't we start with the presidents of lamb.
I'll put this up now the way we'll come back to it
and let's just remind ourselves what the prisoner's dilemma is,
because you guys are all full of Turkey and cranberry sauce and you've probably
forgotten what game theory is entirely
honest.
Let's name these strategies rather than Alpha and Beta.
Let's call them cooperation and effect,
and that would be our convention this week.
We'll call them cooperation,
right?
Yeah.
And the fact is this player a,
and this is play a,
B,
and the payoff is something like this,
two two minus one three three minus one and zero zero.
It doesn't have to be exactly this,
but this will do
all right,
this is the game we're going to play and to try and see if we get cooperation
out of it,
uh,
by,
by having it,
by having repeated interaction.
We're going to play it more than once.
All right,
so let me,
uh,
go and find some,
some players to play here.
This should be a familiar game to everybody here.
All right,
so why don't I pick some people kind of close to the front row.
So what,
so what,
what's,
what's your name again?
I'm going to use the green one over here.
So say again?
Brooks.
Okay.
So Brooks is what it's going to be a player.
[inaudible] I guess be you want,
you play a beat and I've forgotten her name by this.
They just didn't know it.
Patrick.
You're gonna be playing a,
all right.
And the difference between playing this game now and playing this game earlier
on,
the cost is we're going to play not once,
but twice.
We're going to play it twice.
So write down what you're going to do the first time my down,
wait,
what are you going to do the first time?
And just show it to your neighbor.
Don't show it to each other.
All right?
And let's find out what they did the first time.
So it was written down.
Something good and down.
So a Brooks,
when I cooperated,
you cooperated.
Patrick.
I defected.
Patrick defected.
Okay.
Okay,
well that's okay.
Let's play the second time,
right?
Second time to write down.
We're going to do the second time.
At this time I'm going to defect Mutu all right.
So we had,
we had the play this time,
it just wound up here.
So the player,
when we played at this time,
we had a and B and the first time we had defects cooperate or the second time we
had defect effects.
All right,
let's try another power.
What?
Just play.
There's a couple of times and we'll talk about it.
So,
uh,
yeah,
that's fair enough.
How don't we go to your neighbors?
That seems fair enough.
Easy.
So you are Ben.
So shout it out to be the whole yet Ben.
That's a good name.
It's good.
Very good.
Okay.
And you are Edwina,
Edwina,
Edwina and Ben.
Okay.
So when we to make Ben Player B and Edwina player a and why don't you write down
what you're going to do for the first time again.
We're going to play it twice.
All right?
All right.
Where are we?
What are we?
Mix it up.
We can pay it three times and we'll pay it three times.
First Time.
Okay.
We've about three times.
All right.
Both people who were happy with their decisions and,
okay.
So the first time,
uh,
and we know,
what did you choose?
Cooperate.
All right,
so we had that down this time.
So we've got and weeder and we know quite a and Ben B and we had cooperate
defects.
All right.
Second time please.
Cooperate defect.
Okay.
So we're getting rid of going to and fro now.
Uh,
so this was cooperate and defects.
And one more time.
One more time.
Write down,
both players run down.
Had We,
oh,
okay.
So we flipped around again.
Okay.
So we're seeing some pretty old behavior here.
Uh,
who did what that timer and we know what to do.
Do.
Uh,
so we had,
we had this,
is that right?
We had this.
All right,
so keeping my friends for a minute,
I'll just,
we'll just talk about it in a second.
All right,
so first of all,
let's start with uh,
uh,
with Ben here.
Ben,
you were cooperating and the first go.
All right.
So why were you,
why didn't you choose to cooperate the first term?
Shout out to me.
We can hear you.
I felt that if I established a reputation for cooperating,
we could end up in the cooperate.
Cooperate.
All right,
so you thought the by,
by playing cooperate early,
you could assumption I'm going to reputation.
Uh,
and what about later on when you paid it,
you paid the fact that they're after.
What,
what were you thinking there?
I realized that she established a reputation for defecting second.
All right,
so you switched strategies.
Midcourse alright.
Um,
uh,
Edwina you started off by the fact and why didn't you start off by the faxing
shout out to be when he defected.
So I thought he might affect or cause his friend affected.
Okay.
That's a bit tainted by his friend there.
All right.
It's shorter space in the class when they can just be sitting next to it and
then thereafter you cooperated.
Why was that?
So in fact your reputation works in some sense by cooperating early,
you convinced and we knew you would cooperate and then he went on cooperating
even after he defected.
So what,
what were you doing in the third round?
Shout out.
Cooperate because I cooperated.
All right.
Did anyone come back?
Let's talk to your neighbors.
So a Brooks Brooks,
why did shout out why,
why you cooperated in the first round?
And because I was hopeful that he would cooperate.
You were hoping he would cooperate.
All right.
And what did you affect thereafter?
Um,
because I thought he would continue to after he gives it affects anything,
continue to the facts.
And Patrick,
you,
you're the person who just affected throughout here,
uh,
grabbed the mic and who's next day?
Why didn't you just effect,
and this is a short game that make sense,
that effect in the last period.
So the second last periods,
the first period.
So Ah,
all right.
A lot of interesting idea.
So,
so Patrick saying Patrick seeing,
uh,
actually if we,
if we look at the last period of this game,
whatever this last part of the game,
what does the game look like in the last period
and the last period?
This actually is the game,
right?
If I,
if I drew out the game with two periods,
it'd be kind of a hard thing to draw it,
but got a,
an annoying diagram to draw.
But in the last period of the game,
whatever happened in the first period is what?
It's sunk that right?
Everything happened.
The first pair of just sunk.
So in the last period of the game,
these are the only relevant payoffs,
is that right?
And in this sense,
these are the only role of and payoffs looking forward in the last period of the
game,
we know that there's actually a dominant strategy.
And what is that dominant strategy in the last period of the game to be water in
prison as landlord.
What's the dominant strategy shattered out to fact,
okay,
so what we should see in this game,
we didn't actually,
we didn't actually cause cause we had some kindness over here from when we never
did it but okay.
But what we should see in general is we know that in the last period of the game
in period two,
we're going to get both people to faxing.
All right?
And the reason we're going to get both people to fixing it,
it's because the last period of the game is just a one shot game,
right?
There's nothing,
nothing particularly exciting about it.
There is no tomorrow.
And so people are going to the facts.
But now let's go back and revisit some of the arguments.
That's a Edwina and Brooks and uh,
I've forgotten what your looks,
your neighbors called again and bad.
No,
I should with that.
And Ben said earlier,
right?
They,
they,
they gave it quite elaborate reasons for cooperating,
cooperating to establish reputation inc cause the other person might cooperate,
whatever.
All right.
But most of these,
most of these behaviors were designed to either induce or promise cooperation
period two is that right?
But what we've just argued is that in period two everyone's going to defect,
right?
Period two is just a trivial one.
Stage prisoner's dilemma,
we actually analyzed it the very first week of the class and provided we believe
these payoffs we're done.
Period two people come to fact since they're going to defect in period two,
nothing I can do in period one is going to affect that behavior and therefore I
should defects also in period one.
I ain't got to Belabor this point.
We can actually draw up what the Matrix looks like in parade while I'm trying to
do that using the style we did last week.
All right.
I put before two weeks ago before the,
before we went away.
Our answer here,
once again is the matrix we had before and I want to analyze the first stage of
the game in the first stage game.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to add in the payoffs I'm going to get from
tomorrow.
The parents are gonna get from tomorrow or from tomorrow's equilibrium.
Well this isn't going to do very much from me as we'll see you because I'll get
two plus zero tomorrow cause you know I'm playing defect fact tomorrow.
Two plus zero tomorrow minus one plus Zero Nauru three plus zero tomorrow,
three plus zero tomorrow minus one plus zero tomorrow and zero plus zero
tomorrow.
Zero plus zero tomorrow.
Right?
So just as we did with the war of attrition game two weeks ago,
we can put in the payoff from tomorrow.
We can roll back those equilibrium pay off to today.
It's just in this particular exercise it's rather a boring thing cause I'm just
adding zero of everything.
All right.
When I answer to everything when I then just cancel out the Zeros and backwards
started and of course I should defect,
right?
All right,
so what I'm going to see is because I'm going to defect anyway,
tomorrow.
Today is just like a one shot game as well and I'm going to do the cats defects
again.
Now here we played the game twice and got to factor facts.
What about if we played the game three times?
It's the same thing right for the in three times,
but we did play the game three times between Edwina and Ben there.
We know we're going to defect in the third round.
Therefore we may as well to factor in the second to last round.
Therefore we might as well the fact of the first round and if we read it five
times,
we know we're going to all the facts in the fifth round.
Therefore we may as well older faction of the fourth round.
Therefore we have all the facts and the third and so on.
If we put it at 500 times,
we wouldn't have time in a class,
but we've made it 500 times.
We know in that 500th period it's a one shot game and people going to defects
and therefore in the 499th period people are going to affect and therefore in
the 498th period people are going to affect and so on.
All right,
so the problem here is that we get unraveling what we've seen before in this
class.
We get unraveling from the back.
I have a worry that there might only be one Alan unraveling in America.
Is that right?
How many ELLs?
We put an unraveling in America one.
I've just come back from England and my eye,
my spelling is somewhere in the mid Atlantic right now.
I'll leave it as one.
All right.
I'm unraveling
from the back.
Essentially.
This is a backward induction arguments.
Oh,
and he said instead of using backward induction,
we're already using something and perfection.
We're looking at the equilibria and the last games and as we roll back up the
game,
we get unraveling.
So here's bad news.
The bad news is we'd hoped that by having repeated interaction in the prisoner's
dilemma,
we would be able to sustain cooperation.
That's been our hope since day one of the cloth.
In fact,
we stayed at the hung confidently in the first day of the class and we kind of
intuitively believe it,
but what we're discovering is even if you play this game for 500 times and then
stopped,
you wouldn't be able to sustain corporation equilibrium because we're going to
get unraveling of the last stage and so on and so forth.
All right,
so it seems like our big hope that repeated interaction would induce corporation
to Sassy is going down the plug hole.
That's bad.
All right,
so let's come back and modify our lesson a little bit.
So what went wrong here was in the last period of the game,
there was no incentives generated by the future.
All right?
So there was no promise of future rewards or future punishment and therefore
cooperation broke down and then we had unraveling.
All right,
so the lesson here is what the lesson is,
but
for this to work,
it helps
to have
the future,
helps to have a future.
Hi,
this whole idea of repeat didn't traction,
which the future was going to create incentives for the present.
But if the game is coming to an end,
there's going to be some point when there isn't a future anymore.
And then we get unraveling.
All right?
Now,
this is not just a formal technical point to be made in the ivory tower of Yale.
This is a true idea.
So for example,
if we think about,
uh,
um,
CEOs or presidents or managers of sports teams,
there's a term we use for,
there's,
there's a word we use this in the states for a to describe such such leaders
when they're getting towards the end of their term and everyone knows it.
What's the,
what's the,
what's the expression we use?
Lame Duck.
All right?
So we have this lame duck effects.
The lame duck effect at the end of somebody as term undermines their ability to
cooperate,
their ability to provide incentives for people to cooperate with them,
uh,
and,
causes a problem.
So this lame duck effects effects presidents,
but it also affects CEO's of companies.
All right?
But it's not just leaders who run into this problem.
So if you have an employee in your,
if you're employing somebody and you don't,
you haven't,
you may have a contract with the person you're employing,
but basically you're sustaining cooperation with this person because you
interact with them often.
You know you're always going to track with them.
But then this employee approaches retirement,
everyone knows that in April or something and they going to retire.
Then the future can't provide incentives anymore and you have to switch over
from the implicit incentive of knowing you're going to be interacting in the
future to an explicit incentive of putting incentive clauses in the contract.
All right?
So retirement can cause if you're like a lame duck effect.
Timeless.
All right?
How this is even true in personal relationships with your personal relationships
with your friends.
If you think that those friendships are going to go on for a long time,
be the with your significant other or just with the people you hang out with,
you're likely to get a lot of cooperation.
But if as we perhaps most economic,
most of your significant others that are only going to last for a day at most,
you're not going to get great cooperation.
Right?
You're going to get cheesy.
All right?
All right.
No one's rising to that one,
but I guess it's true.
All right,
so what do we call these economics majors?
Relationships.
Okay.
Hi.
These are kind of end effects.
All of these things,
oh,
are caused by the fact that the relationship is coming to an end and once the
ration is coming to an end,
that all those threats and promises of future behavior,
implicit or otherwise are going to basically disappear.
All right?
So at this point we might think,
we might think the following,
you might believe the following,
you might conclude fast.
If a relationship has a known end,
everyone knows the relationship's going to end at a certain time,
then we're done.
I'm going to,
we basically can't sustain cooperation through repeated interaction.
All right?
And that's kind of what this,
what the example we looked at seems to suggest.
However,
that's not quite true.
That's not quite true.
So let's look at another example where our relationship,
a relationship is going to have a new end,
but nevertheless we are able to sustain some cooperation and we'll see how,
okay,
so again,
I'm being careful here.
I said it helps to have a future.
I haven't said it's necessary to have a future.
All right,
so that's,
that's good news for the economics majors again.
Alright,
so let's do
this example to illustrate that even a finite interaction,
even an interaction that's going to end and everyone knows it's going to end,
might still have some hope for corporations.
Let me look at it.
It's a slightly more complicated game here.
And this game has three strategies.
We'll call them a,
B,
and c for each player.
And the payoffs are,
is there's four,
four zero five zero zero down here we'll do zero zero,
zero,
zero and three three and the middle row five zero one one zero zero.
All right,
and we're going to assume that this game,
just like we did with the first,
we're the first one we did prisoner's dilemma.
This game is going to be played twice.
All right?
It's gonna be repeated it.
We played twice repeated ones.
All right,
so let's just make sure we understand what's what the point of this game is a in
this game and the one shot game,
I hope it's clear that a is kind of the cooperative thing to do,
right?
We'd like to sustain.
We'd like to sustain
play off a because then both players get four and that looks pretty good for
everybody.
All right.
However,
in the one shot game in the one shot game,
a is not a nash equilibrium.
Why is a not a Nash equilibrium?
It'd be grab.
There's makes.
Again,
why is AA not an actual equilibrium?
Told us to work with one thing.
Anybody up?
I need to get rid of the memes.
This statement themselves.
This is Casey,
right?
So shout out the best response to the other guy playing A's playing be good.
Good.
So if,
if,
if I think the other person's going to play a,
I'm going to want to defect and play.
Be annotated it again again of ones which I'll get five rather than four.
All right,
I'll defects to playing B and get five rather than four for gain of one.
Is that right?
Right.
So Aa is not a nash equilibrium in the one shot game we've got,
someone's going to call that.
Well that's fine.
And the one shot game.
Yeah.
So now imagine we play this game twice.
There's US playing once.
We're going to play this game two times.
All right?
So now why isn't it,
I'm sorry,
I'll come back to that before I do that.
What are the,
what are the pure strategy and actually quite a burden this game?
Anybody?
So bbs and then actually you whatever the Nash Equilibria and this one shot
game.
Ah,
BB and CC.
All right,
bub.
That there's some mixed ones as well,
but this will do.
All right.
So BB and cc are the,
uh,
appeal strategy,
Nashik,
whatever.
All right.
Now consider playing this game twice.
And last time we adjusted the game played twice while it was prisoner's dilemma
and we noticed that we couldn't sustain cooperation because then the last stage
people weren't going to cooperate and have hands on the first stage.
People weren't going to cooperate.
But let's look what happens here.
If these games played twice,
is there any hope of sustaining corporation?
I Aa in both stages.
Could we have people pay a in the first stage and then pay a again in the second
stage?
All right,
so Patrick shaking his head,
so that's right.
So shake his head up.
He grabbed the other like,
all right,
so,
so why,
why is nothing I can do it?
Why can't we get people to cooperate and play a in both pair of shout out in the
second period,
you're so ended effect in play beat.
Good.
So in the second period,
exactly.
The argument that Katie produced just now and the one shot game applies because
the second period game,
it is a one shot game.
All right.
So we've got no hope of sustaining cooperation in both Perez.
It's called this cooperation.
Okay.
Right.
We call them sustain.
Okay.
We call him cause this to stay in a,
in period two
and the second period.
However,
I claim that we may be able to get people to cooperate in the first period of
the gate.
All right,
how are we going to do that?
So to see that,
let's consider the following strategy,
but
consider the strategy,
right?
Let's try it.
It's going to be
play a
and then
play.
See a
was played
and play
be otherwise.
Okay.
All right,
so this strategy isn't instruction telling the player how to play,
how before you consider whether this is an equilibrium or not.
It's been inverted commerce here as well.
Before we consider whether this didn't an not,
let's just check that this actually is a strategy.
All right,
what does the strategy you have to do?
It has to tell me what I should do it.
Could you give me an instruction at each of my information sets in this two
period game,
each of us,
each of the players in the game have two information sets.
They have an inflammation is at the beginning of the game and they have another
information set at the beginning of period two is that right?
So it has to tell you what to do at the first information set and at the second
information sites and it does.
All right.
It says play a at the first one.
All right,
and then the parent,
the beating of period to what not.
Now I said there's any one inflammation is at there,
but actually there's a million possible information sites depending on what
happened in the,
in the first period to each thing that happened in the first period is associate
with the different information so that I always know what happened in the first
parade.
And at each of those nine inflation stats,
it tells me what to do at the beginning of period two in particular,
it says,
if it turns out that Aa was played then place,
see now and otherwise all the other eight possible inflammation sets,
I could find myself in play B.
All right,
so this is the strategy.
Now,
of course,
the big question is,
is this strategy and equilibrium and in particular,
is it a subgame perfect equilibrium?
Is this,
you stopped getting perfect equilibrium.
Now you'd be a bit more precise if both players were playing this strategy.
Would that be a subgame perfect equilibrium,
right?
Well,
let's have a look.
Okay,
it goes,
I don't see it now.
So let's put both your fourth down.
Yeah.
So to check that,
to check whether this is a subgame perfect equilibrium it,
we're going to have to check what we're going to have to check.
They didn't do says Nash behavior in each sub game.
I think the battery is going on,
man.
Should I get rid of that?
Sorry.
Okay,
I'm going to shout.
Can people still hear me?
People that,
can they get the heavy?
Yup.
Okay.
So we're going to have to see if we can sustain Nash behavior.
Yeah,
thanks.
We're going to see if we can sustain Nash behavior in every sub game.
So let's start with the sub games associated with the second period.
Technically,
is there a nine such sub games?
Depending on what happened in the past,
depending on what happened in the first parade,
there's a subgame following Aa,
there's a sub game following a B,
there's a subgame following,
AC and so on.
Should we?
Okay.
All right.
So for each activity in the first period,
for each,
for each profile in the first period,
there's a sub game.
However,
it doesn't really matter to distinguish all of this.
Oh games particularly carefully here since,
uh,
the,
the cost from the past.
What happened in the past is sunk.
All right.
So we'll just look at them and there's a whole,
all right,
so in period two
in period too
often a I often AA.
All right,
so in one particular,
the one in particular,
there's nine sub games after Aa.
Okay.
This strategy
induces,
and do you see is cc all right.
If people play a in the fifth,
both people like a,
in the first period,
then in the sub game following people are supposed to play a CFC.
Is that a nash equilibrium of the sub game?
What was cc?
It was cc a nash equilibrium.
Yeah,
it's one of our Nash equilibrium.
Let's look up for,
we've got it listed here it is.
So we're playing this nash equilibrium so that isn't actually equilibrium.
So we're okay.
All right.
Oh,
after
the other choices
in period one,
this strategy in juices,
bebe,
that's good news too because Bibi,
we already agreed was a nash equilibrium in the,
in the,
uh,
in,
in the one shot game.
All right.
So in both,
you know,
in all of those nine sub games,
the one off to a and the eight after everything else we're playing Nash
behavior.
So that's good.
What about in the whole game,
the whole game
and the whole game starting home period one,
right.
We have to ask,
do you do better to play the strategy as designated in particular to choose,
uh,
to choose a,
Oh,
what do you do better to the facts.
All right.
What does have a look?
So if I choose a then my,
I remember the other person,
the other person is playing this with this strategy.
So if I choose a,
that might pay off in this period comes from a had is full.
That's my shit.
If I choose a,
they were both playing a on this parade,
I only get four.
Alright.
And tomorrow,
according to this strategy tomorrow,
right?
Tomorrow since we both played a will now put,
both of us will now play.
See,
since we're both playing,
see I'll get an additional payoff of three.
All right,
so tomorrow,
see,
see what a car and I'll get three for a total of seven.
All right.
What about if I defect,
what we get to kids?
Cause I,
lots of possible defections but let's just consider the obvious to faction.
You can check the other ones at home.
So if I defect,
if I defect
and choose B now,
then in this period and this period I will be playing B and my opponent or my
path will be playing a.
So in this period I will get five.
Alright.
And tomorrow,
tomorrow,
since Aa did not occur,
both of us will play B.
Both of us will play a beat and get a continuation payoff of one.
So the continuation pay off.
This time
we'll be following from BB
and I'll get one what do what I've been doing before in this class and put boxes
around the continuation pal just to indicate that they are in fact continuation
payoffs.
Alright,
so if I play a I get for now and the continuation pay off of three for a total
of seven if I play be now.
Yeah,
I gained something now I get five now,
but tomorrow I'll only get one for a total of six.
All right.
So in fact seven is bigger than sex,
so I'm okay.
They won't want to do this to faction.
All right?
I just don't want to write this one other way cause it's gonna be useful for
later.
All right,
so one other way to write this [inaudible].
We've convinced ourselves that this is a,
this is an equilibrium,
but one other way to write this is an,
it's in a more general way,
but in repeated games is to write explicitly comparing the temptations to cheat
today with the rewards and punishments from tomorrow.
All right?
What I want to do is in general,
we just rewrite this as checking that the temptation,
the temptation to
cheat or to fact
today
he's smaller than
the value.
All the reward
minus the value of
the punishment,
but the keywords here are defecting a curse today.
Rewards and punishments I car
tomorrow.
All right?
If we just rewrite it this way,
we'll see exactly the same thing.
Just rearranging slightly.
The temptation to defect today is I get five rather than four of your leg again
of one.
And the value of the reward tomorrow was a value of the reward.
The reward was to play CEC tomorrow and get three.
The value of the punishment tomorrow was to play BB tomorrow and get one.
Right.
And that difference is too.
All right.
So here,
the fact that the temptation is outweighed by the difference between the value
of the reward and the value of the punishment is what enabled us to sustain
cooperation.
Hi,
I'm just writing that more general way cause this is,
this is the way that we can apply in games from here on.
All right.
We're gonna compare
temptations to cheat with tomorrow's promises.
Patrick.
Yeah.
Let me,
let me get you a mic.
Okay.
I don't understand why it's reasonable to think you would play BB in the second
period though.
Instead of you have in the second period you have a temptation to play cc,
even if the person effected on you.
Good,
good.
That's,
that's a,
that's a very good one in white or Patrick saying is how calm where it's all
very well to say we're sustaining corporation in the first period here.
But the way in which we used to spend cooperation was by going along with,
as it were,
the punishment tomorrow,
right?
It required me tomorrow to go along with the strategy of choosing B if I cheated
in the first period.
Right?
And I want to answer this twice,
once disagreeing with him and once agreeing with it.
Okay,
so let me just disagree with them first.
So gnosis tomorrow if the other person,
the other player is going to play B,
then I'm going to want to play B.
All right?
So the key,
the key idea here here is as always a nash equilibrium.
If I take the other person's player has given and just look at my own behavior.
If I think the other person is playing the strategy and hence he's going to play
be tomorrow off drive,
she said,
then I want to by being myself.
So that check is just our standard check.
And actually that's a check that makes sure that it really is us.
I've been perfect equilibrium.
We're not,
we're not putting some punishments down the tree that arising out of equilibria.
They have to be.
It has to be that I want to do tomorrow what I'm told to do tomorrow.
All right,
so that idea seems rights.
Uh,
and I'm gonna go ahead Patrick.
Read it,
cause we're the next thing I know I wanted to go along with as punishment
because if the other person's playing be,
I want to play,
be myself.
All right?
So that's that.
But never think Patrick's onto something and let me come back to it in a minute
and come back to in a minute.
All right?
But what I want to do before I do that,
it's just draw out a general lesson from this game.
And the general lesson is we can sustain cooperation even in a finite,
a repeated game.
But to do so,
we need that to be more than one nash equilibrium.
And the stage game,
what we needed to be is several Nash Equilibria,
one at least of which we can use as a reward.
And another one,
which we can use as a punishment.
I say even if a game is only played a finite number of times,
if there are several equilibria in the sub gay ever severally Korver Equilibria
in the stage game,
which bring this down and show again several equilibria in the,
both BB and cc,
we can use one of them as a reward and the other one as a punishment and use
that difference to try and get people to resist temptations today.
All right,
so that's the general idea here
and it's just right there.
But Patrick,
don't,
don't ever get away with not coming back to your point.
I want to come back to it a second.
All right,
so the lesson here is
if a stage gate,
the stage game is the game that's going to be repeated.
If a stage game
highs
more than one
nash equilibrium in this
van,
we may be able
to use,
okay.
The prospects,
Off playing
different equilibria.
Okay.
Different Equilibria tomorrow
to provide incentives.
Okay.
And we can think of these as incentives as rewards and punishments.
That's rewards and punishments for cooperation today.
Okay.
All right.
In the game we just saw there were exactly two PR strategy now sheik whatever,
and the sub game.
We used one of them as a reward and the other one as a punishment,
I think we were able to sustain cooperation in a subgame perfect.
Equal equilibrium.
Alright.
Now a question arises here and I think it's behind Patrick's question
and that is how plausible is this?
How plausible is this?
Do we really,
it's okay formally,
we write down that the gay even do the math,
this comes out.
But how plausible is this as,
as,
as a model of what's going on in society.
Right.
And I think the worry,
I'm guessing this is the worry that was behind Patrick's question is,
is this,
suppose I'm playing this game with Patrick and suppose Patrick Cheats on me.
The first parade.
So Patrick chooses B when I wanted them to choose a in the first parade.
All right.
And now,
and in the second period,
according to the equilibrium instructions were supposed to play BB and get
payoffs of one rather than cc and get payoffs of three says,
make that,
make that visible,
I guess.
All right,
but suppose Patrick comes to me in the meantime.
So between period one and period two,
Patrick shows up at my office hours and he says,
yeah,
I know I cheated on you yesterday.
All right,
but why should we punish ourselves today?
Why should we,
both of us lose today by playing the BB equilibrium?
Why don't we both switch to the CC equilibrium artful?
That's better for both of us.
It's true that Patrick sang to me.
It's true that I cheated you yesterday,
but why know,
let bygones be bygones are why cry over spilled milk on it.
So he'll use some other sort of,
uh,
saying,
plucked out of the book of attitudes and,
and,
and say to me,
well,
why,
why go along with the punishment that just,
let's just play the good equilibrium now.
Alright.
And if I look at things,
I say,
well,
you know,
it's true.
I got nothing in the first period because Patrick kind of cheated me in the
first parade.
It's Troy got nothing yesterday.
And it's true.
It was Patrick who caused me to get nothing yesterday.
But nevertheless,
that's a sunk cost.
And I'm comparing getting one now we're getting three now why don't I just go
along,
get three and in fact if I,
I moreover this isn't a,
I'm not in danger of being cheated again because if Patrick believes I'm going
to play a c,
he's going to pay seats.
All right,
so that kind of arguments,
that kind of argument involves what involves some kind of communication between
stages,
but it sounds like that's going to be a problem.
Why was suppose it's the case that we are all going to get communication between
periods and suppose it's the haste that someone with the gift of the Gab,
I'm on his way to law school.
Like Patrick is going to be able to persuade me to go back to the good
equilibrium for everybody in period two then we know we're going to play the
good equilibrium in period two and now we've lost any incentive to cooperate in
period one.
And the only reason I was willing to cooperate in period one was because the
temptation to defects was outweighed by the difference between the value of the
reward and the value of the punishment.
If we're going to get the reward anyway,
I'll go ahead and effect today.
All right,
so the problem here is this notion of renegotiation.
This notion of communicating between periods can undermine this kind of
equilibrium.
There's a problem that arises if we have renegotiated.
All right?
So there may be a problem.
Oh
re negotiation.
All right.
It's probably may not be such a big problem for this.
For example,
it may be,
I'll say,
I'll be so angry at Patrick because he screwed me over in parade.
One probably won't go along with the renegotiation and it may also be the case
and we'll see some examples of this on the homework assignments that the many
equilibria in the second,
in the second stage of the game are not such that were that,
that uh,
punishment a punishment for Patrick is also a punishment for me.
What really caused the problem here was in trying to punish Patrick,
I had to punish myself.
I haven't,
you could imagine games and we'll see some concrete examples and next and the
next homework assignments in which punishing Patrick is rather fun for me and
punishing me.
Israel,
the Fund for Patrick.
And that's gonna be,
that's gonna be much harder to renegotiate our way out of.
Right.
There was a question and we get to Mike after the question,
uh,
how he's about,
yeah,
go ahead.
Yeah,
just pointed the microphone and shout.
Yup.
If we're ruling out renegotiation,
can't we divide a devise a strategy for prisoner's dilemma as well,
even though it doesn't have a multiple Nash equilibriums yeah,
so the,
the,
the issue in Britain.
Okay,
good.
So the issue there is in prisoner's dilemma,
we,
we established in the first week that if we're not allowed to make side
payments,
I'm not allowed to bring it outside contracts,
then no amount of communication is going to help us.
All right.
So you're right.
If we can rely on the courts or the mafia to enforce the contract,
that will be fine.
And then communication would have bites.
But you remember way back in the first week when we tried to talk our way out of
of bad behavior in the prisoner's dilemma,
it didn't help precisely because it's a dominant strategy.
All right?
Whereas here,
here Patrick's conversation,
Patrick is verbal agreements to play.
The other equilibrium is,
is an agreement to play on national,
whatever.
That's what's getting us into trouble.
All right.
All right,
so what may help us hear what me avoid renegotiation is simply,
I'm not going to go along with that renegotiation.
I just,
I'm too angry about having been cheated on it and it may be other reasons.
It may actually be that I enjoy the punishment.
Nevertheless,
this is a real problem in society.
I think we should retain this problem,
isn't there?
So a good example is in bankruptcy.
Okay.
Which is one of those words I can never spell.
It seems to have too many consonants in it.
Is that right?
It's approximately right.
Anyway.
All right.
So bankruptcy law are in the u s for the last 200 years has gone through cycles
and it was one way to view these cycles is their cycles of relaxing the law and
making life easier for borrowers and then tightening up again.
All right.
This is not a reason for not,
I mean,
there's not only a recent phenomenon this occurred throughout the 19th century.
That's what typically happened was there was either explicit renegotiation
between parties or negotiation through act of Congress or sometimes through the
act of,
of,
uh,
of the states in which,
bankrupt,
uh,
debtors were,
basically let off or given an easier terms and the Alderman was always the same.
These people are not going to pay back now,
right?
It's clear if I'm from the 19th century,
uh,
often,
if you were bankrupt,
you were in jail.
All right?
Actually worse than that,
sometimes in the,
in,
in the ninth century in England,
not only if you're bankrupt were you in jail,
but your creditors were having to pay the fees to feed you in jail.
All right?
So there you are sitting in jail,
you weren't paying that money back to your creditor and you were actually
costing money to your creditor.
I being in jail,
this seems like a situation that you want to read it.
Do you want to renegotiate your way out top?
You say,
Hey,
let's let these guys out of jail that there'd be productive again and they'll
pay back part of the loans.
Right?
So you had these waves of bankruptcy reform in which a bank in which the,
the,
the uh,
dentist,
jails,
debtors' prisons were closed down.
People were let out,
people were relieved of debt.
What's the problem with doing that?
And does that seem like a good idea?
Right?
After all,
you don't want all these people bank crops,
uh,
in debt,
not paying money back to their credit has anyway.
That doesn't seem like a good situation.
Society.
That seems like a good,
was that renegotiation.
That's a win.
Win.
It's better for everybody.
What's the problem with it though?
Yeah.
What's the,
is kind of a mic down here.
What's the problem with us?
Yup.
Yup,
And incentivizes bankruptcy,
right?
It creates an incentive for people not to repay in the first place and make it
creates an incentive for people to take big risks now.
All right.
And hence it makes bankruptcy if you like or mix mix,
uh,
non repayment of debt more likely.
So this has been going on for a while,
but you see it very much today.
If you read the financial pages of the papers and the in,
in,
in the last few weeks,
there's a big worry in the u s right now about people failing to repay what kind
of debt we're going to.
That's the big worry about mortgage debt,
right?
So both people who are house owners feeling to payback mortgage debt and equally
worrying financial institutions that have,
that have lent a lot of,
for example,
subprime debt now finding I was in financial trouble and you're going to read a
lot in the papers about not letting people out lately out of those,
out of those situations of being in debt and not letting any black out lately
out of bankruptcy.
Right?
What,
what's the tone you're going to hear is bailout.
So bailout.
Okay.
The argument going to be,
you're going to read this,
you don't want the government or the central bank bailing out those financial
institutions who have had apparently taken two large risks on subprime mortgage
debt.
Even though we all agree it's better right now for those financial institutions
not to go under.
And why are we not going to,
even though it's better for everybody if not to go under,
why we're not going to bail them out because it undermines the incentives for
them not to make bad loans to start with.
And to a lesser extent,
you're going to hear that on the data side as well.
You're to have some people say we shouldn't be bailing out people who took,
who took on the bad loans to borrow it.
It took on bad mortgages to uh,
to finance their houses again for bailout reasons.
All right,
so this is an important trade off you'll,
if you go on to law school,
you're going to see a lot of out this,
this kind of discussion.
And this is the discussion of trading off ex ante efficiency
and ex post efficiency.
Sometimes as Patrick pointed out in the game just now,
the ex post efficient thing to do is to go back to the good equilibrium or if
you'd like to bail out these firms who've made bad loans.
However,
from an ex ante point of view,
it creates bad incentives to people to make those loans in the first place and
the ex ante point of view.
It created the incentive for people to defects in the first part of that game.
All right,
so this theme of ex ante versus ex post deficiency,
it's not what I'm going to go into any more in this class,
but it should be there in the back of your minds when you all end up in law
school in a few years' time.
Okay,
so so far what have we done?
We've been looking at repeated interaction and seeing if it's consistent and
cooperation and the first thing we learned was that if they repeated interaction
is a final interaction.
If we know when it's going to end,
we know when the interaction is going to end.
Then sustaining corporation's going to be hard because in the last period
there'll be an incentive to defects.
We saw you get round that to some extent if games have multiple equilibria,
but in the game,
right?
Prisoner's dilemma,
we're really in trouble.
Things will unravel from the back.
All right,
so now let's mix things up a little base by looking at a more complicated
variety of repeated interactions rather than just play the game once or twice or
three times.
Let's play the game under the following rules,
but we'll go back to our same players.
How many mikes are still out here?
Then I took them both back.
Is that right?
So I'm thinking I'm taking both the green and the blue mic.
I'm getting them back to our players.
All right,
so this is to the Brooks and this is to Patrick.
and going to have Brooks and Patrick play prisoner's dilemma again.
I'm hoping I haven't deleted it.
Maybe I did.
Oh right.
It doesn't matter what we,
we,
we know the payoffs.
We're going to have them play prisoner's dilemma again.
But this time in between every play of the game,
I'm going to toss a coin.
Actually,
I'll toss the coin twice and if that coin comes up heads both times,
then the game will end.
But otherwise they'll play again.
All right,
everyone.
Everyone's how we're going to do,
we're going to play prisoner's dilemma at the end of every period.
I'll toss a coin twice.
I might get Jesus to said I'm not going to toss a coin twice.
If it comes up heads,
both times the game's over,
but otherwise the game continues.
All right?
So both Brooks and Patrick should get ready to play.
And the payoffs,
this game,
it's just what we had before.
So it's just remind ourselves about the power slide game.
Aha.
So we've got to cooperate the fact cooperate to facts
two,
two
minus one three
three minus one and zero.
Sarah,
I'm gonna keep score here.
So this is,
uh,
Brooks
and Patrick.
All right,
so putting pressure on these guys.
It's a,
let's write down what you're going to do the first time.
All right,
Brooks,
the fiber.
Better cooperate.
All right.
Weight.
Hey,
waiting some payback from early.
All right.
Round two.
Are you going to toss a coin?
Oh,
I have to tell you.
I have to write.
Thank you going to have to find the car without,
I look at that.
Thank you,
Allie.
Uh,
twice.
Just twice
heads
heads again.
So the game is over.
That was the last one.
Let's just for the,
just for the sake of the class,
let's pretend that it came up.
Tails.
Okay.
We'll cheat a little bit,
which each little bit.
Okay.
So we're playing a second time,
uh,
just with a little bit of saying hi to someone else that someone,
someone less honest to toss the coin.
Brooks,
what do you,
what do you choose?
Oh,
I'm dictating [inaudible] again.
All right.
Patrick,
cooperate.
Corporated Eddie's.
Patrick's.
He was very trusting.
Yeah.
All right.
It's just the kind of her time.
Okay,
good.
Thank you.
All right,
so,
uh,
Brooks,
I'm going to defect again.
Yep.
Perfect.
All right.
Okay.
So this time it was somewhat end date.
So,
so what happened this time is just talk around to beds.
So they're Brixton.
Patrick,
we're playing.
All right.
Patrick cooperated a bit at the beginning.
Brooks defected throughout Brooks.
Why did you defect?
Shout out so everyone can hear you.
All right.
Why did you defect right from the start of the game?
Uh,
because,
because last time it didn't work so well.
The gloss,
we're going to walk so while,
okay.
Okay.
That's fair enough.
But even after Patrick was corporate,
so the cooperating you went on defecting.
So,
uh,
why,
why then?
Um,
because I got out because I wanted to get the higher payoff from,
I thought either he would continue cooperating and I could affect,
um,
and yeah.
All right.
So I thought he'd gone corporate,
which in fact he did.
He did.
Patrick,
why aren't you cooperating early on here?
Shout it,
shout out to people.
Get people here.
So it's a two head rules.
Like you have a 75% chance of having another game.
So with those payoffs,
um,
even one period,
the payoff of cooperating twice is the same as the factory once.
So like additional periods,
it's better if you can continue cooperating and a percentage is high enough that
you figure there's a good enough chance of,
of,
of getting sick to go.
Even after Brooks defected,
the first period you went on cooperating,
but then the after hit,
after the second period you gave up as a defecting or they go on to the fourth
period,
what would do have done defected.
It does affect it again.
Right.
And,
and,
and fifth period.
Well,
if she kept attracting,
I would keep the of,
all right,
so what was,
what Patrick's saying is he started off cooperating,
but once he saw that Brooks was defecting,
he was not a switch to the and,
but basically as long as she went into effect,
he was in a switch to stick with the faxing.
All right,
let's try a different path.
So why don't we switch it over to your partners there?
So,
so,
uh,
to ban the here and um,
I'm sorry.
Edwina.
Alright.
Right
briefing.
Well,
we'll put,
we'll put twice.
All right.
But people have told us when he was a stand out,
I want to see these people.
So Thomas second are,
these are players that when people at the backs,
which we know,
we know who playing this,
he said,
we know this is Ben.
All right?
All right,
good.
All right.
Okay.
So,
uh,
Edwina,
usually you sit down and get to be so you can actually write things down.
Okay.
So,
all right,
so Edwina and Ben goes with no strategy.
[inaudible] strategy.
Yep.
Edwina,
what did you choose?
Cooperate and wieners.
Cooperating.
Ban.
Cooperate.
Aha.
Okay,
let's toss a coin heads than tails.
So we're okay.
We're okay.
So we're still playing.
Okay.
Edwina,
cooperate.
Ben?
I chose cooperate.
All right,
so the cooperating
tales against,
you're still playing.
Cooperate.
All right,
so there's still cooperating some pain in the voice.
This time
has a nice house.
Right down.
We're going to do
had we let defect,
Ben Cooperate.
All right.
So thanks for going through nicely that
we had such a nice class going on there and everything.
All right sir.
It was heads then.
Tails.
All right.
So we're still playing
Edwina defect,
right?
Defect.
Alright.
Jay Townsend House.
We're still going
to fact to fact.
All right,
let me,
let,
let me stop it.
They will pretend.
We'll pretend that we're turning them head to head.
So let's,
let's talk about this,
right?
So we had some cooperation going on here.
Both people started cooperating.
So a Ben Wa,
why did you cooperate at the beginning?
Shout out to people to hear,
why don't you come ride?
Well,
going along with Patrick's reasoning,
I felt that if we could have the cooperate cooperate in the long term with the
75% chance of continuing playing,
that it would be a worthwhile investment.
All right.
Until I realized that I'd started to cause this cause come back to in a second.
Let's get you guys to stand out.
We to be able to,
people going to hear you.
I think maybe when you stand up you shout more.
That's not up again.
Yes.
Edwina.
Wait,
why?
Why didn't you,
so you also started cooperating.
Why didn't you start cooperating?
Okay.
Um,
for the same reason.
Same reasoning.
Okay.
So the,
so the key thing here is why,
why did you start to factor?
You heard the big sigh in the class.
Why,
why did you start the fact check at this stage?
Um,
because we'd had so many,
I mean the coin has cut off task that had to come to heads heads sometime.
So I started thinking that
this is reversion to the mean of the coin.
I thought maybe.
I mean I said I don't know.
Alright.
So what do I say about the relation to evacuate if economic majors that are in
the past anyway.
All right,
so,
uh,
so and we ended affected and then Ben,
you switched after that.
Why did you switch?
Okay.
Um,
because once Edwina started affecting,
I felt that we revert back to the defective act equilibrium hall.
Right.
All right,
so,
so thank.
Thank you.
Good.
Thank you guys.
All right,
so there's,
remember this strategy here,
people started off cooperating and I claim that at least been banking contract
in a segment.
I think Ben Strategy here with something like this,
I'm going to cooperate and I'm going to go on cooperating as long as we're
cooperating,
but if at some points,
if at some points had wiener defects or the mind of someone I need to facts,
then you know the game,
this relationship's over and we're going to paint the fact forever.
Is that right?
That that's kind of a rough description of your strategy.
All right,
all right,
and then wiener was more or less playing the same thing.
In fact,
it was heard,
affected,
but once she defected,
she realized it was over and he went on to factor.
All right,
so the strategy has a name has just be clear what the strategy is.
Their strategy says,
play,
see you,
she's cooperates,
and then
then
play.
See if no one has played
d
and play d
otherwise.
All right,
so start off by cooperating.
Keep cooperating as long as nobody's cheated,
but if somebody cheats,
this relationship's over.
We're just going to affect forever.
All right,
now these strategies are famous strategy.
It has a name.
You want to know what the name is?
Okay.
This is called the grim trigger strategy.
The grim trigger strategy.
Okay?
The grim trade strategy.
So this strategy,
again,
it says we're going to cooperate,
we're going to cooperate.
But if that corporation breaks down ever,
even if it's me,
you breaks it down,
then I'm just going to defect forever.
Alright.
Now we're going to come back next time as you can see if this is an equilibrium,
but before,
but,
but there's a few things to do.
First.
First,
let's just check that it actually is a strategy,
right?
What does it mean to be a strategy?
Again,
it has to tell us what to do at every information said I could find myself fast
and this gay you man,
he's potentially infinite,
right?
So potentially there's an infinite number of increment of inflammation.
So it's,
I could reach.
So you might think that writing down a strategy that gives me an instruction at
every single information sets,
it's going to be incredibly complicated once we go to games that are potentially
infinite,
right?
Cause that need to be an infinite number of instructions.
But it turns out actually it's possible to write down some strategies rather
simply at least if they,
if they are simple strategies and this example is one,
this tells me what to do at the first information site it says,
please see it.
Then tells me for every information said I find myself at in which only
cooperation has ever occurred in the history of the game.
I'm going to go incorporating,
please see and it says for all other histories for all other inflammation sets I
might find myself at play d.
All right,
so it really is a strategy.
All right.
No,
this is very different behavior.
Both of his,
we played with the same players.
This kind of behavior is very different in both games actually is very different
than the gate and then the then the behavior we saw in the game that ended,
they get them with two periods or three periods.
What is it essentially that made this difference?
What's different about this way of playing prisoner's dilemma where we toss,
we had Jake toss the coin versus the way we played before and we just played for
five periods and then stopped.
What's different about it?
Somebody has talked to our players.
Okay,
so is the Mikes let Patrick,
do you have your mic still Patrick?
Why?
Why is this difference?
We don't know when the game is going to end or if it's going to and so there is
no last period.
Good,
good.
So our analysis of the,
of the game before the analysis or the prisoner's dilemma,
when we knew it was going to end after two periods,
five periods,
whatever it was was we all knew it was going to end right.
There was a clearly defined last period where people are going to retire.
We knew the month in which they're going to retire.
When presidents are going to step down,
we know they're going to step down that parade.
When CEOs are going to go,
we know they're going to are,
we don't always know.
I think I got this.
Pretend we did it right.
Alright.
So what's different about this game is every time we play the game,
that is a probability.
In this case,
a three quarters problems see that the game's going to continue to the next
permit,
right?
Every time we play the game with prevalency 0.75 there's going to be a future.
All right?
There's no obvious last period from which we can unravel the game and the way we
did before.
I just remind ourselves the way in which cooperation,
our analysis of cooperation broke down in the filing and repeated prisoners'
dilemma was that when we looked at the last period,
we know people are going to defect and once that thread is loose we can unravel
it all the way back to the beginning.
But here,
since there is no last period,
that unraveling argument never gets hold.
All right?
Now instead we're able to see strategies develops lake.
The grim trigger strategy and news is that the grim trigger strategy has a
pretty good chance of of of actually sustaining corporation.
So in particular,
as long as people play this strategy,
they are cooperating.
All right along the people that play a stretch,
Well,
it turns out that had wiener eventually gave up that strategy.
But how'd you got on playing it?
They're gone cooperating forever.
All right,
but of course there's a question here and the question is,
is this in fact an equilibrium?
Right?
We know that people play this way.
We get cooperation,
but the question,
that's what the,
the thousand dollar question is,
is this an equilibrium?
So what do we have to do to check whether this isn't equal?
Everyone,
not,
we have to mimic
the argument we had before.
We have to compare the temptation to defect today and compare that with the
value of the reward to cooperating and the value of the punishment from
defecting tomorrow.
All right,
so this basic idea is going to reemerge.
Having said that,
let me now delete it.
So I have some rob,
we're going to have to come to,
to show this as an equilibrium,
we need to show that the temptation to did affects the temptation to cheese in
the short term is outweighed by the,
the difference between the value of the reward.
And the value of the punishment.
All right,
so let's set that up.
Okay,
let's put the temptation here first.
So the temptation and prisoner's dilemma to the temptation to cheat today is
what?
I'll get three rather than two.
Is that right?
So if I had to facts when Edwina affected,
he said we knew the fact thing and this period she got a pay off of three rather
than the payoff of two she would have got from cooperating.
All right?
So there's a temptation here is just three minus two.
And let's be clear.
This is a temptation
today.
We want to compare this with
the value of the reward
minus the value of
the punishments.
But the key part observation is that these occur
tomorrow.
Here's a cat tomorrow.
All right?
So since they occurred,
tomorrow we have to weight them a little bit lower.
All right?
So in general,
in general,
the way which we're going to weight them tomorrow is we're going to discount
them just like we did in our bargaining game.
We're going to wait tomorrow's payments by Delta.
Yeah.
Where Dell says less than one.
All right.
Now.
Why am,
why is Delta less one?
Why?
Why are we waiting tomorrow less than payments today?
Why a payments tomorrow worth less than payments today?
Because tomorrow might not happen.
All right?
There are other reasons why.
By the way,
it might be just wearing patient to get the money today and we can just wonder
the pay off in a hurry.
Or it might be that she wanted to take the payment today and put it in the bank
and earn interest.
And are there other reasons why money today you might be more valuable than
money tomorrow.
But in gay,
you miss the most important reason is tomorrow may not happen right tomorrow.
By tomorrow you might be dead or if not dead,
at least Jake's thrown out,
thrown two heads in the coins.
Alright,
so delta has on one
because the game may end
cause the gay man now watch the value of the reward.
The value of the reward is going to be the value.
Oh,
see
forever.
But I want to be calf up forever.
It's see forever.
But of course it isn't really forever cause the game my end.
All right,
so why by forever,
I mean until the game ends and maybe a bit more careful.
Actually the CC,
isn't it?
The value of CC cooperate,
cooperate forever.
And here we're going to have the value of
Dee Dee
forever.
I once again,
since it's the forever here means until the game ends.
All right,
so this is the calculation we're going to have to do.
We're going to have to compare the temptation.
That was easy.
That was just one with the discounted value difference between the value of
cooperation and the value of defecting.
Alright,
let's do the easy bits now and then we'll leave you in suspense until Wednesday.
Let's do all the easy base.
All right,
so watch this delta.
In this case and this particular gay men,
what was the probability that the game was going to continue
with the public of the game was [inaudible] wasn't one of the properties of the
game was going to end.
Poverty ending was 0.25 so delta here was 0.75 that's easy.
All right.
Yeah,
a second bit.
That's relatively easy
is what's the value of playing dd until the game ends.
Once people have cheated,
you're going to pay d forever.
Hey,
we are Edwina's chasing here.
You're going to get Dee Dee in this period,
dd or this part and so on and so forth.
Until the game ends.
In each of those periods,
you're going to earn zero.
So this is just a Xero,
which leaves us with a messy beds.
Watch the value of cooperating forever.
Let's try and do it one.
We got one minute,
let's do it.
So in every period of which we both cooperate,
what do we earn during the next period?
We're going to it next.
We're at the beginning of the game,
right?
We cooperated in the first parade.
On the second period,
we cooperate again.
What payoff do we get from cooperating again?
We get to right,
we get to,
and then Jake tosses this coin and with probability Delta,
we continue.
All right,
and we're going to cooperate again.
So we've probably Delsa we cooperate again and get what?
Pay off the next period
two again.
And then Jake tosses the coin again.
All right,
so now he's just the coin twice.
So it was probably Delta squared.
We're still playing and we get to,
and then Jake [inaudible] the client again and see if it comes up other than
hate head again.
And that's the,
the Delta cubed we get to and so on.
All right,
so your exercise between now and Wednesday,
it's figuring out what the value of cooperation forever is.
Figure out this equation and find what value fund,
whether in fact you're more than equilibrium for people to go,
oh,
pick it up on Wednesday.